[Music]
hey everyone I am here at the booth one
of our partners of the Year 2023 I'm
here with the CEO Tony seoan Nvidia is
actually our one of our partners of the
year right here today I have Mike Thomas
here from Nvidia we are at the VMware
Booth here at Google Cloud next and I am
with Cheryl young and I also want to
point out that they are a partner of the
year so congratulations on that hey
everyone right now I'm at the slalom
Booth with Kristoff
[Music]
deas so can you tell us a little bit
about the exciting news for the
partnership you know not only announcing
the the A3 instance coming to Market
here in the next month we're super
excited about that being generally
available U but also doubling down our
partnership on platforms like vertex AI
so really was an exciting and in a
whirlwind of the last three days but
really having Jensen and Thomas really
kick things off was no better way to
start the conference for us what we
tried to do with our booth for this year
was incorporate uh some of our great
partners and some of the actual uh great
Google clout customers as well that are
using Nvidia Tech on Google cloud and
are really scaling their businesses from
everything from a generative AI
perspective to monitoring your models uh
even doing some really cool demos with
data proc but for this in particular on
the vertex AI front again we're super
jazzed up about our partnership with
vertex Ai and in particular one of those
containers and stacks is Triton Triton
our inference server it's where we
really recommend for customers to scale
their models out so they can support any
framework any model and when you combine
trit in with vertex AI you kind of get a
great onew punch to scaling your
inferencing and having that auto scale
capability that vertex brings to the
table means that your inferencing of
your machine learning or deep learning
models is not going to be delayed based
on people setting up infrastructure
which is
huge one of the most exciting areas for
VMware VMware and Google cloud is Google
Cloud VMware engine and so I'd love to
learn a little bit more about that so
we're we're so excited that we have this
joint solution uh Google Cloud VMR
engine that both Google and VMware can
sell through the VMware Cloud Universal
program at VMware so we're showing how
easy it is for customers who are used to
using VMware products on Prem can now do
that in Google cloud and they're getting
a VMware as a service stack provided by
Google on dedicated Google Cloud nodes
um and they're getting vsphere vsan NSX
and hcx help them very seamlessly move
their workloads to Google cloud and not
only that they can also connect them to
Native Google cloud services like big
query and get even more analytics Ai and
more insights about their
customers Kristof tell us uh about slom
slalom is a organization that helps
people and organizations dream bigger
move faster and build better tomor for
all using platforms and especially
Google Cloud what are some projects that
you've been doing tell us a little bit
more about the partnership as well yeah
of course so uh we actually had an
awesome session on stage with our
customer Arvis bank and uh they had a
session about how we've been working
with Google and slm and the customer
helping them transform the way they do
banking but also walking through the
Journey with them and helping them
change the way they work uh change the
way they have a career progression of
people who might have been working on
Legacy Technologies for a long time and
now are new doing it in a new way in the
cloud so tell us about Zada what you're
doing in the partnership what I'm most
proud of this year is how many customer
stories we have to tell how many
sessions we participate in mainstage
developer conference uh V stages around
here and you know and it wasn't like
pulling teeth it was like every customer
wanted to tell their story and you know
the ones that were not involved in the
stories but attended are all raving
about about how valuable this conference
was for them I think the biggest change
has been a feeling of optimism and
excitement obviously driven and
accelerated by all the work that Google
has done in the realm of gen and I have
to say in my 17 years of working with
Google in the Enterprise I've never seen
Google respond so swiftly and so uh um
powerfully as I have in the realm of gen
and now when we go to market I can say
like we are going to Market with Google
cloud with a market leading stack in gen
and it feels good to be able to say that
well congratulations on all of that and
I really hope that next year you're on
our list again for partner of the year
because you have what we're going to try
we're going to go for it second of years
yes okay well congrats so much on all
the thought of success amazing well
thank you so much Mike for the
incredible partnership and we look
forward to conducting all these
workshops with customers and I just want
to congratulate slom and you all for
partner of the Year this year and we
can't wait to see what you do next well
congrats on Partner of the Year and
thank you so much for an awesome partner
thank you so much and we're so excited
to be a partner of the year in the
infrastructure and virtualization area
yeah um so great to collaborate with
[Music]
Google